if you've been a subscriber for some
time you may have seen my analyzed
reviews in the past for films like Enemy
Prometheus or only God forgives while
planning this discussion I decided that
style was perfect for this video so
please sit back relax and enjoy the
problem with horror movies today I was
inspired to make this video for a few
reasons I saw an Australian horror film
called the babadook and because of
having to sit through 2014 releases like
the quiet ones
Annabelle and most recently Luigi it's
also due to reading opinions of this
year's psychological thriller oculus but
mostly what I want to discuss is
audience expectation how that can ruin a
good horror film and more importantly
have audiences forgotten what real
horror is in my opinion the horror genre
is the most widely varied in film
there's countless subgenres monsters
slashers zombies ghosts nature aliens
torture comedy and my personal favorite
psychological this is perhaps why I've
always gravitated to scary and
suspenseful films as a genre the use of
imagination is almost unlimited but
lately
imagination is a word that Studios
horror filmmakers and as a result the
audience has completely forgotten about
here's a comment I recently came across
on IMDB okay this is meant to be a
horror right you wait all through film
to see this thing just to be let down
yes the atmosphere is creepy but the end
ruined it imagination is for kids I want
to see the monster at the end big
letdown this comment was in reference to
the babadook which I recently had the
pleasure of seeing if you haven't seen
it yet don't worry I won't spoil
anything for you it's a dark soulful
film about a mother and son dealing with
grief and a monster that lurks in the
dark
this this commenter seems to be upset
that he didn't receive much of a look at
said monster he also seems to have
completely missed the point of the film
the babadook is the best horror film
i've seen in 2014 it deeply unsettled me
and not just because of its effective
atmosphere and cinematography the true
terror of the film is its implications
the hidden meaning of the monster and
it's excellent exploration of grief and
depression all of this was beautifully
realized in an oscar-worthy performance
by the luminous se davis who perfectly
displayed the looming insanity that
consumed her character the film
currently stands at 96% on Rotten
Tomatoes and 90 on Metacritic mature and
discerning horror fans have shown major
appreciation for the film's lack of
cheap jump scares and the tasteless
scare tactics of many modern-day horror
films and yet that's also the problem
for many audience members today the term
scary has a completely different
definition for some it seems a film
scare level is measured by how many
times a loud noise or sound effect made
them jump in their seat this is the
curse of the jump scare it is the single
easiest scare to accomplish there's no
real effort put into it and the exact
same technique is used every time all
sound suddenly drains from the movie no
one speaks there's no music and then
suddenly an ear piercing jolt rings
through the theater and everyone jumps
because a really loud noise just
happened often it's revealed to be one
of the main characters friends or some
other type of false scare please observe
this scene from the original and highly
effective horror film Halloween
this is how a false scare should be
portrayed look at it this way and this
may be a little vulgar but it's true
horror movies should be like sex you
don't want the audience to blow their
load too early now bear with me on this
one if your audience begins to associate
everything frightening in the film with
loud noises and sound effects then your
film will build to nothing the climax of
the movie won't be effective in the
least because the audience has already
had all the tension released too early
by countless jump scares making what's
actually supposed to be frightening near
the end tiresome let's examine that
scene again but how it would be
portrayed in 2014
with this absurd noise all tension has
deflated from the film and the music has
now told us that the sheriff is the one
- fear not Michael Myers the jump-scare
is the cheapest tactic used in horror
films today and the most frightening
thing is its rampant use has caused many
audience members to forget what true
horror is another deciding factor is
marketing and audience expectation a
primary example I often reference is the
village
a film by frequently maligned director M
night Shyamalan many view this as the
film where Shyamalan began to lose his
talent but did he or did our
expectations for the film we wanted to
see let us down the problem was the
marketing something Shyamalan has since
regretted approving the trailers made
the movie out to be a creature feature
when in reality it was a period piece
romance
I remember being vastly disappointed
with the twist ending because my friends
and I had spent months excitedly trying
to figure out what the creatures would
look like only to discover the film was
actually a love story in hiding years
later the film has since become more
respected especially for Roger Deakins
gorgeous cinematography unfortunately
since most horror directors have zero
clout in the industry they rarely have a
say in what goes into their trailers so
most good horror films are miss marketed
to try and appeal to a mass audience
mentality for that reason the trailer
for the babadook is marketed as a
creature feature the trailer has over 1
million views on YouTube that's over 1
million people expecting a monster movie
who will leave the theater disappointed
that they just watched a challenging and
mature psychological thriller because
all they wanted to see was a monster
let's talk about oculus which is
currently my second favorite horror film
of the year behind the babadook I've
seen it twice now and upon the second
viewing was even more impressed with the
seamless nonlinear storytelling that I
was the first time
it's a film about an evil mirror and its
reign of terror on a helpless family
told across many years I'll never forget
my experience at the screening when the
credits ended I was literally the only
person praising it everyone was saying
the exact same thing to me
really Chris you liked it why it wasn't
even scary I fear this is because of
something I'll reiterate audiences have
forgotten what real horror is did I jump
in my seat when I watched oculus no not
that I recall
isn't that great the writer director
Mike Flanagan cleverly uses the story of
two children witnessing their parents
slowly go insane their father chaining
their mother to a wall as she rips out
her own teeth the eventual repressed
memories of adulthood and the looming
terror of mental illness these things
are scary in fact they're terrifying and
yet movies like Annabelle a shameless
cash-grab to leech off one of the better
horror films in recent memory and Ouija
a movie about a fucking board game
continued to top the box office let's
talk about James Wan the director of
insidious the conjuring clearly the man
understands the genre but you might be
thinking Chris you're being hypocritical
both of those films were littered with a
loud sound effects and jump scares yes
they were but they weren't false all of
the terror generated by those films or
from things you're actually supposed to
be scared of one understands what modern
audiences find frightening while also
respecting his more mature audience
members by avoiding false scares and yet
Studios don't care about anything I just
said
all they care about is the numbers it's
been made painfully obvious since 1978
Halloween that horror films can be made
for cheap and rake in absurd profits The
Blair Witch Project and the seemingly
endless Paranormal Activity series has
spawned
new sub-genre in horror called
found-footage according to box office
mojo the budget for Blair which was
$60,000 and it raked in 248 million
Paranormal Activity was made for a mere
$15,000 and grossed an astonishing 193
million dollars worldwide remember the
universally hated chernobyl Diaries yeah
it grows 37 times its budget wasn't
Apollo 18 such a gigantic misfire not
really even though it only grows 25
million dollars worldwide it still made
five times its budget wasn't the devil
inside terrible guess what that thing
grossed 101 times what it cost to make
nearly everyone I've talked to agrees
that Annabelle was an awful movie as of
right now that film has a worldwide
gross of 231 million dollars on a budget
of just 6.5 million or how about we G
currently this film has just had its
second weekend at the box office and has
already grossed 42 million dollars
worldwide on a budget of just 5 million
in its first weekend more people went to
see this board game movie than the
excellent action thriller John wick and
in its second weekend the film basically
tied with Nightcrawler one of the best
films of the year for first place I'm
disgusted by this I've talked to not one
single person that liked Ouija knocked
one I've been told by some people that I
pay attention to the box office too much
and that I shouldn't let it bother me
unfortunately it bothers me because I
know this is what the studios are
looking at they don't care if anyone
actually liked Annabelle or Ouija or any
of those found-footage movies I just
mentioned they will make sequels and
prequels until they stop making money
I've made this video to implore people
to reevaluate
what good horror is I'm concerned by the
rising trends I see with today's
moviegoers and if you are too
please share this video in the hopes
that we can generate awareness for this
disturbing pattern that's infecting the
horror genre what are your thoughts on
modern-day horror let me know you think
in the comments section and as always
thanks so much for watching everyone and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes